the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay guys welcome to the first filmed
and hands-on installation of 2201
introduction to ionizing radiation mike
short i'm the department's undergrad
coordinator multi ER 2201 instructor but
i also want to introduce you to Amelia
Trainor in the back who's one of the
three TAS for the course she took it
last year everything's still very fresh
in your head I bet so cool so she'll be
she and Kayne Yau and Caitlin Fisher
will be with us all throughout the term
so if there's something that you don't
like my explanation for you've got three
people who just took the course and
struggled through my own explanations
and can say it in a different way so
let's start off by taking your knowledge
of physics from the roughly eighteen
hundred's education of the Gir general
Institute requirements up till 1932 when
the neutron was discovered and I would
argue that this particle is what makes
us nuclear engineers it's the basis
behind reactors it was what
differentiates us from the high-energy
physics folks and everything because we
study these and use them quite a lot and
so we want to retrace Chadwick steps in
discovering the neutron and this is the
only time you're ever going to see me
have a bunch of words on a slide it's
not a presentation technique I like but
this paper is awesome in the clarity and
expressiveness of saying I ran this
experiment found something unknown I use
basic conservation of energy and things
you learned in 801 and 802 to prove that
it has to be in Neutron that there
Neutron must exist it's elegant and
brilliant and I want to walk you guys
through it then do you get a chance to
read the Chadwick article yet okay I'll
show you where that is because hopefully
by now you're all aware that we have a
learning module site it's where I'm
going to post everything it's where
you're going to submit everything for
the class but I'll save till the end of
this class to go through the actual
syllabus because I want to get into the
physics so let's bring your knowledge
from classical mechanics and enm up till
about 1895 when Wilhelm roentgen used
x-rays and use them to well image
something for the first time ever
showing the contrast between bone and
tissue is able to illuminate the bones
in a hand and then about a year later
the x-rays got a whole lot
so by then it was known that there were
high-energy photons that had
differential contrast between different
types of material your later after the
nicer x-ray JJ Thompson conclusively
proved that there is an electron by
taking these cathode rays as they were
called at one point and sending them
through two charged plates and he was
able to show a slight deflection so
these cathode rays as they passed
through an electric field change
direction a little bit and from the
change in direction you may not know the
mass or the charge but you can get the
mass-to-charge ratio because if you guys
remember from 802 from electricity and
magnetism as a charged particle passes
through an electric field its deflected
and the amount of that deflection or the
curvature is based on the mass-to-charge
ratio so we Chadwick knew that electrons
existed this was a known thing as well
as alpha beta and gamma rays so the
electrons that came out of the nucleus
were later renamed beta rays and at this
around the same time Ernest Rutherford
and Paul Villard working in Canada and
France discovered that there are some
heavy charged particles that have very
little penetrating power while Paul
Villard discovered that there are some
other radiations they think he called it
produced by disintegration of nuclei
that have very high penetrating power
and they named them alpha beta gamma in
order of their penetrating power or
their range and so it was later figured
out that these were also high-energy
photons so gamma once this is something
to note is that gamma rays x-rays light
whatever it's all photons however once
this pops back up gamma rays emanate
from the nucleus so when we refer to a
gamma ray we mean a photon that came out
of a nuclear interaction or a nuclear
disintegration not an electron
transition so this is one this is what
makes a gamma ray a gamma ray is where
it comes from
otherwise it's it's a photon behaves
just like any photons so what did
Chadwick see in 1932 this is the first
one-page article that he sent out to
nature to say I found something weird so
he found out that when you take alpha
particles from polonium so let
say we had a source of polonium sending
off alpha particles which haven't told
you what they are yet emits a radiation
of great penetrating power
when it hits a foil of beryllium and it
was not known what these things were so
in goes the alphas to beryllium
something happens and something comes
streaming out that couldn't be explained
by current theories it was also noticed
that when hydrogen was placed in front
of it when a piece of hydrogen in the
form of wax which contains a lot of
hydrogen was put in front of it the
amount of ionization increased as
measured by what's called an ionization
chamber and a no silly graph nothing
more than a almost sealed chamber a
piston with some charge on it that would
then deflect as it were to pick up
positive or negative charges it would
move inwards or outwards and send a
signal an electrical signal to something
like an oscilloscope so this was a way
that you could figure out how many ions
were created by this highly penetrating
radiation interacting in the ionization
chamber and the estimated that with the
old theories if this highly penetrating
thing were a photon or a gamma ray it
would have to have an energy of 50 times
10 to the 6 electron volts or fifty MeV
he said okay well if that's to be
basically the experimental observation
say a fifty MeV photon must be
responsible for the ionizations that we
saw and so again this is what the
experiment looks like where you've got
polonium source naturally emitting alpha
rays they hit a foil of beryllium they
produce what he did not know at the time
was neutrons we actually do know that
beryllium produces neutrons pretty well
beryllium is an interesting Neutron
multipliers undergoes what's called an N
to n reaction where one Neutron comes in
two neutrons can come out and it
translates into something else and we'll
go over what this notation means what
these nuclear reactions mean if you
don't understand it
don't worry the whole point of today is
to open up questions that will spend the
rest of the semester closing and
answering
so again if you're lost don't worry it's
the first day of class and it's your
first day of modern physics so not to
worry this is an actual picture of what
it looked like in the paper a simple
polonium source on a disk that was made
by the natural decomposition of radium
into polonium a piece of beryllium a
vacuum chamber because it was already
known that the alpha particles coming
from polonium have an extremely short
range we're going to figure out why as
part of this class but without that
vacuum there the alpha particles
wouldn't make it to the per ileum so
that much was known what wasn't known
was why are we getting so many
ionizations they attributed it to what
they called a process similar to the
Compton effect to tell you what that is
in 1923 Arthur Compton figured out among
other things Compton scattering where a
photon can strike an electron the photon
changes energy the electron picks up
some energy they exit at very well-known
angles and they transfer very well-known
amounts of energy so this is how they
knew how much energy the photon if it
were to exist should have and they said
the process was analogous to Compton
scattering because they said in this
case a proton would be ejected it would
take a lot of energy to eject a proton
using a photon and Chadwick saw this and
said well if we ascribe this phenomenon
to a Compton recoil we should see about
10,000 ions we actually saw about 30,000
so there is more ionization going on
than can be explained by what's going on
in addition those protons should have
arranged an air of about 1.3 millimeters
and they saw much more so this says
something simple is theory and
experiment don't match there's got to be
a different theoretical explanation if
the experiment was correct and so
finally what I love the last sentence in
this the quantum hypothesis a quantum
was the way they referred to a photon it
was called the quantum back then a
little packet of energy can
we be upheld if we forget about
conservation of energy and momentum now
I'll ask you guys from 801 and 802 so
Shawn when can you cook Wendy can you
throw out energy and momentum
conservation that's pretty much Brett
you can't a situation probably wasn't
given to you where you can just throw
away conservation of momentum and energy
in fact nature gives us three quantities
that we can measure and conserve mass
momentum and energy and throughout this
course if something's not conserved
you've probably got the math of the
physics wrong so this is something to
remember throughout the course in our
derivation and in your problem sets is
conserve mass conserve momentum conserve
energy just like what was taught in 801
in 802 so I'll call your answer correct
you don't remember a situation because
well didn't exist and that's what
Chadwick notice he said theory and
experiment don't work unless we throw
out conservation of energy and momentum
whether this was a kind of
passive-aggressive thing to say well
this clearly can't exist or he was
suggesting maybe it doesn't work I don't
know I wasn't there but later on about a
year later he published a follow-on
paper
confirming the existence of a neutron by
reconciling these differences in theory
and experiment so he restated what he
saw before this is the first paragraph
of it and again said that radiation
excited in beryllium whatever happens
after the alpha particle came out at a
highly penetrating radiation distinctly
greater than that of any gamma radiation
found from radioactive elements
something's different and I want us to
take a second to digest this this is the
part I actually want you guys to read so
take a minute and read through some of
the stuff and then we'll begin
explaining his argument
so let me know when you guys are done
reading
okay I see some folks starting to look
down so let's take this apart and figure
out what was Chadwick saying he was
saying that if a quantum was responsible
for this energy a photon then we can
write a nuclear reaction I'll write it
in the notation that we use now which
would be beryllium 9 the only naturally
occurring isotope of beryllium plus an
alpha particle would lead to carbon 13
plus a gamma ray and that gamma ray
would take away the energy from this
reaction so now we can start to figure
out is energy conserved could this gamma
ray actually exist and if it does
doesn't account for the ionizations that
Chadwick saw so for each of these
isotopes we know a few different
quantities we know what's called its
rest mass energy which is its rest mass
times speed of light squared this should
look familiar to everyone I've seen it
on t-shirts all over campus and it may
take two or three weeks to really wrap
your head around what Einstein's
equation really means is that mass and
energy are equivalent you can express
mass in terms of energy and vice versa
and you will be doing so to conserve
energy and mass in nuclear reactions one
of which is written right here so if
each of these things has a given rest
mass energy let's say rest mass energy
of beryllium and a rest mass energy of
an alpha particle and this alpha
particle maybe had some kinetic energy
it was moving pretty fast so we'll give
that a the symbol T for kinetic energy
because that's what you're going to see
in your notes and in the reading and
everywhere and then this carbon-13
nucleus has got to have a rest mass and
a kinetic energy and then this gamma ray
is going to have some gamma energy now
the question is is the mass and energy
conserved in this equation what we're
actually starting to write is what's
called the Q equation or the sort of
universal mass and energy balance for
any kind of
nuclear reaction so let's say we have a
large initial nucleus I and some small
particle I'm moving at it with some
great speed and after some reaction
occurs you have a small final particle
leaving and a different large final
particle relieving they don't
necessarily have to be the same let's
give these particles designations one
two three and four in the end we should
be able to write the difference in
either total energy or total mass of the
system as this value Q Q is let's say
the amount of energy that turns into
mass or vice-versa so let's say energy
transfer and so if we start writing some
mass conservation equation we can say
that the mass of nucleus 1 plus the mass
of nucleus 2 should equal the mass of
nucleus 3 plus the mass of nucleus 4
plus however much energy from nuclei 1
and 2 turned into energy into 3 & 4 we
can also write the same thing for their
kinetic energies in this case the finals
are on the end so I'm sorry I should use
T for kinetic energy not
so what this is saying is that if some
mass has turned into energy at the end
that energy had to come from somewhere
it had to come from the initial kinetic
energy or conversion to mass to energy
from this reaction and so notice that
now you can actually express the masses
of the nuclei in terms of their energy
if their initial and final kinetic
energies and this right here is what
we're going to be spending the first two
or three weeks deriving using and
exploring in order to balance nuclear
reactions and explain why they are the
way they are so let's make sure we'll
keep this nuclear reaction up here
because Chadwick proposed a different
one to explain what he saw and some of
the evidence for this was that he put
some aluminum foil in between the
beryllium where things were being
liberated and the ionization chamber and
oscilloscope or a Silla graph as he
liked to call it and that way by putting
more and more pieces of foil in there
you can deduce what's called the range
or the distance that the radiation will
travel before it stops by losing energy
through a whole host of different
processes that we'll be working through
together if this were to be ascribed to
a proton then it should have had a
certain range in air by this curve B
right here instead he found this curve a
where things moved about three times
farther than could have been explained
if that were a proton to be liberated by
all this stuff so he's saying okay
something's got more penetrating power
we know now that part of the reason for
this is if there's a neutron and there's
no charge on it then it's not going to
interact with the electrons in matter it
won't even see them whereas protons or
any other charged particles will see the
electrons in matter and will interact
with the electrons and the nuclei so a
little flash forward to say we can
explain this pretty simply with what we
generally know but this was the first
time somebody had to come up with the
sign of explanation and it was quite
hard
and so moving on he can say well I know
what proton should be injected from
paraffin I know a formula to describe
what quantum or photon energy had to
create them and then instead he says
this is where his major hypothesis is
either we relinquish conservation of
energy or no-trump neutron or adopt
another hypothesis and this was already
sort of put forth by Rutherford back in
the 20s that there may be a neutron but
there wasn't any proof and this is what
provided the proof he gave an alternate
nuclear reaction if there were to be a
neutron which had roughly the mass of a
proton then let's write a second one
down here I'm going to erase these extra
notation and will write the competing
nuclear reaction below and he said that
let's say we start with beryllium 9 plus
an alpha particle could instead become
carbon-12 and a neutron so I'd like to
ask you guys right now to work this out
are both of these reactions balanced in
terms of mass are there the same number
of protons neutrons and electrons on
either side and just to let you know an
alpha particle is better known as a
helium nucleus so that means that
there's two protons there's four protons
plus neutrons and beryllium nine has
four protons and nine protons plus
neutrons and carbon-12 has six protons a
neutron has zero protons so in each of
these and I'll fill in the other ones
here so that's a four for two and six do
we have the same number of protons and
neutrons on both sides of both equations
I see a number of heads and one person
saying yes we do so both of these
reactions are balanced in terms of mass
the next thing to do is balance them in
terms of energy now they can both be
balanced in terms of energy because you
could attribute the change in the amount
of mass from here to there and attribute
that to the energy of the photon that's
when you'd have to have a photon of
energy around fifty MeV but if a proton
I'm sorry a photon of energy around
fifty MeV can't explain what we saw
instead if there is something like a
neutron which also has its own rest mass
and its own kinetic energy and that
neutron were highly penetrating it could
explain what Chadwick saw and so the the
masses and things of these nuclei were
fairly well known back then - well six
significant digits based on some very
careful experimentation and all he did
is say alright let's take all of the
energies in this reaction remember how I
told you over here you can write any
nuclear reaction in terms of its kinetic
energies and the difference will give
you the Q value which you can attribute
to the conversion of mass to energy
that's what Chadwick did right here he
took the full reaction saying here's the
mass of beryllium the mass of the alpha
particle the kinetic energy of the alpha
particle note that he assumed that the
kinetic energy of beryllium was zero it
was just sitting at room temperature
does anyone know the approximate kinetic
energy of atoms at room temperature
order a magnitude even it's around a
hundred to a thousandth of an Eevee or
an electron volt so when we're talking
about beryllium whose kinetic energy
will say is around 0.01 evie and the
alpha particle whose kinetic energy was
around four times 10 to the 6
evie you can see why it's neglected and
you can do that too
you do not have to account for the
initial kinetic energy of a nucleus at
rest this is the first aprox
nation that we tend to make to the Q
equation to just have fewer variables
and don't worry if you don't remember
this now because we have a whole lecture
on the Q equation and so finally he said
all right we'll subtract all the masses
were left with the kinetic energies and
a little bit of excess rest mass that's
got to be this has got to exist and so
this inequality has to be satisfied
which indeed it was using this
inequality he said that the velocity of
the neutron has to be less than its
kinetic energy if it had all of that
energy 3.9 times 10 to the 9 centimeter
per second indeed it was lower not by
that much but it still satisfied this
criterion so things are checking out
that's pretty cool he looked at another
nuclear reaction that was known at the
time if you were to bombard boron 11
with helium you end up with nitrogen 14
and either well either end up with
nitrogen 15 and a photon or nitrogen 14
and a neutron explaining another
reaction that wasn't as well known
before so I'd like to write this nuclear
reaction because I want you all to get
very familiar with writing nuclear
reactions let's say boron 11 plus an
alpha particle will say it has a mass of
four becomes neutrons or so nitrogen 14
and a neutron we also have a shorthand
of writing this nuclear reaction which
I'll use on the board for speeds sake
usually if you put the initial nucleus
and the initial incoming radiation comma
the exiting radiation and the final
nucleus these two right here are
equivalent this is just a shorthand for
nuclear reactions this is what you'll
tend to see because it's a lot easier to
write this shorthand and parse it
visually than it is to parse a whole
nuclear reaction so I just want you to
know if you don't know what these are
just remember to stick the arrow here
stick plus signs and for the parentheses
and you've got the same thing and using
these you should be able to very quickly
determine
is this reaction balanced what's
actually going on and there will be
tabulated values of Q values or energy
amounts for these sorts of reactions and
all sorts of tables I'll be showing you
and so finally he figured out what the
energy or the mass defect of the neutron
should be does anyone know what a mass
defect is this is another kind of core
concept let's say you were to want to
make an atom of helium so you would have
to take two protons whose masses are
very well known and two neutrons and
bring them together so if you were to
have let's say the initial mass would be
two times the mass of a neutron plus two
times the mass of a proton and the final
mass is just the mass of a helium
nucleus you'll actually find that the
initial mass does not equal the final
mass in bringing nuclei or nucleons
together they actually release what's
called their binding energy it's what
keeps the nucleus bound together there's
a little bit of mass turned into energy
and so you know how we like to say the
hole is usually more than the sum of its
parts
in nuclear engineering the hole is a
little less than the sum of its parts
definitely is not equal and Chadwick was
proposing that a neutron should actually
be made up of a proton and an electron
in very close proximity and since the
masses of the proton and the electron
were known he said well if we bring the
proton and electron very close together
to have an overall neutral neutron
particle it should have roughly that
mass defect or that difference between
the energy of its constituent nucleons
and the energy of the assembled nucleus
and you'll hear the words mass defect
and binding energy used mass defect is
in terms of mass in either you can give
it in kilograms or in atomic mass units
or amu or in let's say MeV C squared and
you'll also hear the binding energy just
given in things like MeV I want to show
you where you can find these things now
we'll give you the single most useful
website that you'll be referring to and
I've posted it up on the learning module
site so now is a good time for me to
show you that the site exists and let me
just clone my screen real quick so
wireless hdmi thing so it takes a sec to
pop back up
great has anyone not been to this site
yet it's okay it's you don't have to be
embarrassed okay about half of you so I
recommend tonight that you start looking
through this site one make sure that you
can log in because you'll need to log in
to see some of the copyrighted materials
that I've posted and two because this is
where you'll be posting all your
homeworks getting the assignments
checking due dates especially if I
postpone a problem set I'll put on an
announcement and post it here so you
guys this is like the place to look for
everything and in addition I've posted a
lot of useful materials for you guys
they're all at the bottom and the top
one is the Kairi table of nuclides
anyone's seen this kind of thing before
we have posters of it down on all the
first floor classrooms in building 24
this is our go-to chart when you want to
find out all of the nuclear half-life
radioactive decay and decay of energy
probability of certain interaction
whatever this is where you go so let's
take a look at well helium 4 since we've
been talking about it better known as an
alpha particle and you'll notice a few
different quantities visible the atomic
mass 4.00 to 603 to AMU and this is
another tip I want to give you guys
right now don't round these numbers
that's one of the major trip up points
if you say that's approximately four or
4.00 three you probably won't get the
pset questions right because a
thousandth of an a.m. you can still
represent almost an MeV of lost energy
so let's say you have a nuclear reaction
that liberates a one mega electron volt
or one MeV gamma-ray and you get the
fourth digit wrong in one of your mass
calculations it's like that gamma ray
didn't exist and you won't get the
answer right so again the word to the
wise do not round you'll also see what's
known as the excess mass or the binding
energy so this binding energy right here
if you were to take two protons and two
neutrons and bring them together and
look at the difference in masses from
let's say the same old formula as before
you would get the difference of twenty
eight thousand two hundred ninety-five
ke V or about about twenty eight point
two nine five 673 MeV again don't round
let's figure this out right here so we
have twenty eight point two nine five
six seven three MeV and there's a
conversion factor that you should either
memorize or write down either way it's
good it's about nine thirty one point
four nine MeV per atomic mass unit this
is your mass energy equivalence that
you'll be using over and over and over
again and again don't round those last
two digits are important so by taking
this energy and dividing by this
conversion factor you can figure out how
many atomic mass units are lost in terms
of actual mass when you assemble an
alpha particle from its constituent
pieces and the rest of the stuff we will
get into later it's not really relevant
to today's discussion but it's
definitely relevant to today's course
cool okay and then on to one of the last
things that he mentioned is some
predictions to say okay let's say this
Neutron exists it doesn't have charged
most matter interacts with other
matter by virtue of Coulomb Bacoor
charge interactions if the neutron has
no charge it shouldn't really seem
matter except for nuclei and this is
exactly what he said is the electrical
field of a neutron will be extremely
small except at small distances because
he proposed that a neutron is a proton
plus an electron so once you get to
around the radius of the neutron you
might start to see some charge but not
before and so most other matter unless
you have a head-on collision with a
nucleus neutrons won't see it and that
helps explain why the neutrons had such
high penetrating power or high range
because they just went streaming through
most materials invisible to the
electrons so very forward-thinking and
turned out to be very correct and then
finally as a kind of mic drop conclusion
came up with the finalists for the final
concluding statements it is okay we know
there's a neutron we know it's mass the
actual mass of the neutron is about
1.008 7:00 a.m. you so within 0.1% of
Chadwicks calculations and predictions
based on 1930s equipment which is
strikingly awesome
and there you have it that's the
discovery of the neutron using most of
the concepts that we're going to be
teaching you here in 2201 so right now
i'd say you're a scientific knowledge if
we don't count what you read on the news
it's roughly around 1850 when all the
E&M stuff was being figured out we are
gonna bring you screaming into the 1930s
and by about month one will hit the
present day when we could start to talk
about the super-heavy elements like the
ones that were discovered last year I
think there was even some this year but
we'll look at a physics today article
from last year get to the point of
explaining why super-heavy elements
might be stable why are we even looking
for them where do cosmic rays come from
how do we know that they're cosmic rays
and not something else how can you tell
a reactor turns on anywhere in the world
by measuring different bits of radiation
which is an active defense project that
folks are pursuing right now lots of
really fun questions and speaking of
questions do you guys have any questions
about what we've explained here
how we've retraced Chadwicks discovery
of the neutron from basic nuclear
science principles so who here's seen
these nuclear reactions before cool this
is something that I hope folks would
cover in high school but with a general
trend of watering down science education
I didn't want to make any assumptions
I'm glad to hear this was covered was
this covered at MIT you guys relying on
highschool knowledge okay good not good
but good I know where you are not good
that MIT doesn't teach anything nuclear
until year two that's okay you guys
along with the physics department will
get at least a twentieth century
knowledge of physics and how 21st by the
at the end of month one so I want to
come back to the stellar site and
specifically the syllabus I've taken a
lot of care to write a very detailed
syllabus of what we're going to do what
I expect of you guys what you can expect
of me and what we'll be doing every
single day so if you want to know what
we're gonna be doing if you have a class
that you miss and you want to know what
notes you're gonna miss it's all written
up here I want to get right into
assignments because everyone wants to
know what am I responsible for oh not
too much
nine problem-sets three quizzes the
final exam is just a quiz it's only
worth twenty four percent of your grade
instead of twenty to get the math to
work out because I eliminated one
problem set to avoid running afoul of
MIT regulations about not assigning
things at the last week of class but
there are three quizzes so the final
exam is just another quiz it's not a
super high stress crazy thing because I
don't see a point in doing that you can
make your assignments however you want I
don't care as long as I can read them
but I do ask that in the end you submit
a PDF file on the stellar site and the
reason for this is my first course that
I ever taught at MIT as a professor or
the Graduate modules
22:13 intro to nuclear systems and 22:14
intro to nuclear materials
I accepted paper submissions and by week
three I had to microwave them because
three or four times I definitely saw
blood and there
also some weird stains that I didn't
want to explain so I added they had the
habit of unstaple Aang microwaving Andry
stapling the piece sets before grading
so the digital world is sterile I'm not
a germaphobe I just don't like blood in
my house especially if it's not mine so
I ask that you guys submit PDFs on the
stellar site they're due at 5:00 p.m. to
make sure that you're done and you can
go home and relax or work on something
else
I used to some haps things do at
midnight and I had every submission was
11:59 p.m. I'm not gonna do that anymore
do make sure to submit 15 minutes early
so if your computer or the stellar site
has trouble send me an email or a text
or whatever saying I'm trying to submit
and it's not working here's a backup or
I'm leaving something under your door
and if you want my cellphone number
that's also my office number it's also
my only number it's in the MIT directory
so if there's some the merchants that
you need to make me aware of please do
communicate I'd rather you tell me then
be worried about not telling me and then
find out later so we all clear on that
cool as far as what the assignments are
each assignments going to be about 50%
basic calculations working out things
like these to make sure you've mastered
the material that you understand writing
nuclear reactions you can balance a Q
equation you can tell me about what your
cancer risk would be from a certain dose
of material so this is like when you go
out in the real world the sort of
calculations everyone would expect you
as a nuclear engineer to be able to do
and then 50% of each problem set is
either going to be analytical questions
of considerable difficulty this is MIT
or not just here to give you the basics
so that you can regurgitate a textbook
on to the first person who asks we're
here to make sure that you can go
farther because you guys are the future
of this very small and diminishing field
at the moment if you look at the nuclear
power in the u.s. I would say growing in
terms of the world but not in terms of
the US and you guys are going to be in
charge of leading this field and
determining where it's going to go so
you've got to be up at the cutting edge
and we're going to take you to the edge
of your abilities my favorite kind of
problems to give one sentence for the
question 5 or 10 pages for the answer if
you don't get the trick now that's okay
it's perfectly it's
perfectly fine not to figure out the
answer in the end in fact I'll usually
give you the answer for the analytical
questions because I want to see your
approach I'm not interested in you
nailing the answer I'm interested in
seeing how you think and copious partial
credit will be given for the one you
think so if you have a missing step and
you say I don't know this step I'm going
to assume variable a and keep going you
will get credit for the subsequent steps
I want to see how you think from start
to finish and how you cover for holes
that you can't get through so everyone
clear on that partial credit yes use it
to your fullest ability the other half
of the problem sets will have take-home
laboratory assignments it's not just
enough for me to tell you about nuclear
engineering you have to see it for
yourself and you have to feel it for
yourself and once in a while you'll get
a mild electric shock by yourself if
things go wrong but that's ok it happens
to the best of us I got zapped by our
you guys have all made Geiger counters
right does anyone not made a Geiger
counter yet oho ok it sounds like we
need to run another workshop well our
Geiger counters rely on a neat little
boost converter power supply that takes
9 volts and steps it up to 400 volts via
some switching things that means you
have 400 volts on a big metal tube and
if you're working on your circuit and
happen to brush against it you get zero
current so it doesn't hurt you in the
medical sense but it hurts I also have a
dance I call the 60 Hertz shuffle it's
the high speed shaking that you do when
you're connected to 60 Hertz somewhere
from the wall outlet none of you guys
will be exposed to this but done it
enough times that I have a name for the
dance if you get 400 volts you'll just
kind of scream and I don't care how
manly men you guys are everyone makes
the same pitch scream with 400 volts
we're all equal in the eyes of
electricity for these laboratory
questions I'm going to ask you to both
complete an assignment where you'll for
example measure the half-life of uranium
measure the radioactivity of one banana
confirm or refute the linear
no-threshold hypothesis of dose and the
experiment itself won't take that long
but I want you to write it up in proper
documented format using these sections
so I'm gonna be teaching you guys how to
write scientific articles so actually
this is a kind of good time to ask you
guys how would you define the word
science Luke what do you think gaining
knowledge by fitting theories to
empirical evidence okay so I hear
knowledge gaining by some sort of well
justified and accepted means right
Monica what do you think
[Music]
cool
let's say the study modeling an
abstraction of the natural world in two
ways we can understand see Jared what
would you say oh there - Jared's oh I
wanna hear both and then I'll yeah
we said okay cool and other Jared yeah
okay cool I like these and these are the
these are the generally accepted
theories and descriptions I've heard of
science and I want to pose a question to
you guys if a tree falls in the woods
and nobody's around to hear it can it
win the Nobel Prize it's kind of an
expression so if somebody discovered the
neutron and they wrote up their findings
and prove that it exists and they put it
in their desk and the house burned down
and the person died was the neutron
discovered what does discovered mean so
to me science is equal parts everything
you guys said and communication if you
discover something and you don't tell
anyone the information technically
doesn't exist it dies with you and we
don't want that to happen so I want to
make sure that you guys both understand
the science and understand how and the
importance of communicating it
effectively to people because that's the
other thing you're gonna be doing as
leaders in this field is explaining
things
you better believe when Fukushima
happened I mean I was a postdoc at the
time I was not a person I guess in the
academic sense people here treated me
very well when I was also very aware
that I was not one of the greats still I
am not old enough yet I was getting
calls all day all night from news
agencies saying you're at MIT I saw your
name on the directory do a radio
interview and tell us all if we're gonna
die and you can only imagine what the
professor's on this hall we're dealing
with so folks were traveling around
answering things left and right I ended
up doing some weird podcast on a
Brazilian news channel that I don't
think he ever got aired and stopped
doing it after that you as undergrads
even might be called if somebody wants
to know something and so it's best that
you not only know the material but you
can convey it effectively briefly an
away
that your audience can understand the
audience for these articles is any
undergraduate in any engineering program
anywhere that's your lowest common
denominator not to say that that's a bad
thing but it is the audience that you
want to aim your writing at so what I
want you to be able to do is say what
you did why you did it and what it means
in communication terms this means a less
than hundred word abstract a very brief
synopsis of what you did and why it's
important
that's the teaser this is the trailer to
make somebody read what you actually did
and see why they care this is the main
method and currency through which
scientists communicate as articles of
this type an introduction and background
which says why are we studying this
problem and the answer is not because I
told you to and your grade depends on it
I want you to think about why this
problem is important and put it into
context and give any of the scientific
background to understand what's going to
come next
like the experimental section describe
what you did an ad gritty scientific
detail this is usually the easy part
I put this gamma Dre in this bucket and
it made this color and I made this noise
you know whatever a results section
where you show all of your data in a
discussion section notice that these are
different you want to separate your
actual results from your interpretation
of your results because someone else may
have a very different interpretation of
results for example Chadwick somebody
found that beryllium bombarded by alpha
particles emitted radiation of great
penetrating power that's the result the
interpretation or discussion said it's
probably a Compton like effect from a
photon by separating your results and
your discussion you allow people to
mentally say like okay I get your
results I believe that you found these
numbers I have a different explanation
and you all may have different
explanations for what you see in your
own labs because you're also probably
going to get different results and then
finally a conclusion where you quickly
risa mirai's or major contributions your
abstracts the teaser your conclusion is
like your reacts tracked with the
context that
people now believe or don't what you did
and think about how you guys read
articles so who here has read scientific
articles before more than half of you
let's see
Alex what do you read first that's right
okay I'm glad you said that was my next
question is you read the abstract the
next thing you reads the conclusion the
next thing you usually read is skim
through the results in the figures and
see if it's worth looking at then if
you're like oh okay this is worth my
time then you slog through and read
everything to make sure you understand
it all so when you're writing these
articles think about who's reading them
and will how they read them is if you
guys don't tend to read an article from
top to bottom neither will your audience
and that's true most scientists skim
things because we have a lot to read so
that's okay and I am very interested in
you guys completely documenting your
experiment pictures are also awesome to
use accuracy of results in analysis so
did you round when you weren't supposed
to did you have a clear numerical typo
that you can't explain and the
readability of the report I want you to
spend time making this readable I expect
that this part of the assignment will
take roughly five hours or as the basic
questions will take roughly three to
four hours depending on how well you're
doing and that leaves three hours of
class time and a couple hours for
whatever else happens life let's call it
since you've never written these before
wait a minute I shouldn't say that
who's written these kinds of things
before anyone here wrote a scientific
article - okay three cool so most of you
haven't and that's where I assumed you'd
all be we have a whole lab dedicated to
scientific communication called the comm
lab run by someone who happens to be my
wife four doors down we live and work
next to each other it's pretty cool and
you get an automatic three day extension
on a lab assignment if you go to the
comm lab there are three reasons for
this one I want you to get better grades
I want you to learn how to communicate -
I don't want to spend time trying to
figure out what you were trying to say
so better articles means less grading
time for me and three okay let's just
say it's two reasons that's enough and
for everything except for the quizzes
it's perfectly okay to work together as
long as you attribute who did what you
write your own articles don't Xerox
anything and say who took the data so if
the whole class wants to get together
and take one set of data and work for
that fine if you all want to do the labs
yourselves which I highly recommend fine
but I'm not going to tell you how to do
the lab assignment in certain to this as
long as you say what you did and I want
all of you if you haven't yet to head to
integrity down mit.edu to see our
official policies on what is considered
plagiarism what is considered working
together what's considered academic
honesty I will assume because it's on
the syllabus and I'm telling you now
that you've all read this and that there
will be no cheating it's just not
something that's part of my job
description and I don't want to deal
with it which means I won't deal with it
which means the consequences will be
severe so I don't think I'll have to
worry about that and then for the late
policy it's just 10% of the value of
assignment for each calendar day not
each business day so if you're running
really late and you haven't started an
assignment the day it's due better to
take the 10% penalty and do really well
then hand in nothing on time so keep in
mind how can you maximize the points in
this course is I'd rather you hand in
something good late than terrible on
time so if you really need that extra
day if MIT gets crazy take it 10% of a
problem set is point four points on your
grade it's not that big a deal then as
far as the syllabus I want to show you
very quickly we've got when things are
due I'm going to change these dates that
basically just shift them all forward by
one day to account for the new Tuesday
Thursday classes so I've got when the
problem sets are due and Friday's
recitation activities if there aren't
too many questions on a particular
Friday I have a lot of fun stuff in
store for you for example tomorrow we're
going to be talking about radiation
utilizing technology including plasma
spider coders one of which we have set
up in my lab
like to show you because it's a way that
you can coat materials and other
materials and you have to generate this
beautiful glowing purple plasma in order
to do so
so you ionize nitrogen you induce
sputtering which is a radiation damage
process which we'll be going over to
coat things and other things there will
be once in a while where I have to shift
a class in to recitation because I'll be
at Westinghouse or in Russia and I think
that's only twice during the whole year
so you won't miss any classes we'll just
use the recitation time and then other
times we'll be doing measuring the
radioactivity of banana ashes or once we
talk about electron interactions we're
going to go use a scanning electron
microscope the carrot at the end of the
stick to make sure that you guys do well
the top two people performing on the
quizzes get to pilot and choose the
samples for the SEM and elemental
analysis and the focused ion beam
demonstration so you guys get to pilot
something that's let's say is
complicated as a Space Shuttle but deals
with things much much smaller so I'll
put you in the driver's seat in the
machines of our lab and you get to bring
whatever you want to analyze and find
the elemental analysis of and use the
world's smallest machining instrument
that can cut 5 nanometer slices of
things using processes that we're going
to discuss in this class so the better
you do the more you get to use it and at
the end we'll have a nice debate I call
arguing with Greenpeace when we'll talk
about now that you'll have known all of
the nuclear science and engineering and
can speak scientifically about topics
we're going to go after a lot of
societal misconceptions do cell phones
cause cancer does living near a nuclear
power plant cause cancer does arguing
with Greenpeace cause cancer whatever
it's going to be so I want to make sure
that you're well-equipped and confident
enough to go out there and hold your own
in a vigorous debate with an angry
emotional environmentalist you guys will
be calm peaceful and informed
environmentalists after all that's why a
lot of us are here is we want nuclear
energy to happen because we care about
the environment
there's other people that don't want
nuclear energy to happen because they
care about the environment to each their
own I guess motivations but I want to
make sure you're well equipped
to also tackle things like is food or
radiation that there's all sorts of
websites with dancing babies and weird
geo cities like graphics saying food or
radiations evil you won't find a lot of
scientific articles that's the case and
to see if you'll put your lets say
cancer risk where your mouth is the last
day of class will have an irradiated
fruit party or I'll be buying only the
kinds of fruit that can be imported into
the US because food irradiation is done
otherwise the USDA would not let it in
the country and this is mostly things
like mangosteens from Thailand pineapple
from Costa Rica and interestingly enough
Hawaii is considered a different country
agriculturally it is so far away that
they have different agricultural pests
and without a radiation we couldn't
import some of the produce from Hawaii
because it could decimate some of the
crops in the continental US pretty crazy
huh yeah it's the fifth it's the what
it's at the 49th state but
agriculturally a different country so
it's about five till so I'm going to
stop here and we will start with
radiation utilizing technology on Friday
tomorrow
downstairs in room 24 121 and then we'll
move over to my lab at two o'clock to
see the plasma sputter coder
you